[Applaudissements]
1996 une année noire dans les souvenirs
de la police j'apprends que je pense
aussi de vos suicide mais
malheureusement j'ai pensé au sujet des
autres collègues
la france sort d'une vague d'attentats
le plan vigipirate mobilise les forces
de l'ordre sur tout le territoire
épuisement découragement au total 70
policiers se sont suicidés cette année
un mort tous les cinq jours cette
semaine un gardien de la paix une femme
de 48 ans a tué ses trois enfants avant
de mettre fin à ses jours avec son arme
de service
27 janvier à beauvais en ile de france
ce premier suicide dans un commissariat
en sous-effectif révèle le malaise de
toute la profession pour constate sur
beauvais que la délinquance et n'est pas
une délinquance de province n'a faire
d'un souvent aux gens un problème au
rallye les maux de la société
donc il est bien évident que ça des
risques d'exécution de ces clauses x que
l'individu nous sommes des hommes avec
des policiers un manque de suivi
psychologique des conditions de travail
dégradées dans tous les cas ce que
dénonce les agents c'est un manque
d'écouté de la hiérarchie un manque de
considération sont là les problèmes de
plus en plus loin des pressions
pratiquement de suite on a on a aménagé
ce qu'on a on se retrouve
de marché dans la voie publique offert
les policiers courent on se retrouve
assis dans un bureau à ghajar garder des
détenus
et ça c'est quelque chose qui suit
oubliant toute la carrière
les cas s'accumulent après en double
suicide à montbéliard le ministre de
l'intérieur jean louis debré se rend sur
place pour écouter le malaise des
policiers
nous voulions voir comment faire en
sorte d'éviter ces drames si c'est
possible et de mettre toute notre
activité toute notre passion toute notre
volonté faut faire en sorte que ça se
révèle le moins possible renfort
d'effectifs cellule d'écouté des
solutions d'urgence sont déclenchés à
l'échelle locale dans les commissariats
touché le ministère de l'intérieur a
créé un dispositif national dans la
foulée le service de soutien
psychologique opérationnel basé à paris
qui existe toujours aujourd'hui